[Music]
if you've been watching the skies as
closely as i have lately then you'll
notice that space has been getting a
little bit busier
[Music]
the recent launch from elon musk's
spacex caps off a two-month window in
which richard branson's virgin galactic
and jeff bezos is blue origin
have all sent civilians into space to
give more people a chance to become
astronauts
all three of these companies have
different goals and different ways of
launching fire fire and they all go to
different parts of space for different
reasons you see the earth from space
changes your relationship with this
planet but all three have one thing in
common they'll take you into space for a
price
our first paying customer feel like you
got your money's worth sir
[Laughter]
how much well somewhere between around
half a million and 55 million dollars
now unfortunately i do not have that
kind of money but let's assume you do
and you want to know what kind of
experience these companies are offering
and how they differ well my millionaire
friend allow me to be your space travel
agent i'm going to break down exactly
what these companies are doing grab your
spacesuit let's go
first off i want to dive into these
companies business models
they've all invested enormous amounts
this is our engineering test article
about dragon spacecraft and all had
setbacks over the years
some of which have been fatal
but they have different reasons for
wanting to go into space
virgin says it's primarily focused on
pioneering human space flights for
private individuals and researchers
while it is conducting some research and
training trips its main offering is what
it calls a transformative experience
where paying customers are flown into
suborbital space it says that it aims to
one day fly some 400 trips a year we're
here to make space more accessible to
all bezos blue origin is also offering a
space tourism experience but bezos says
he has plans to go much deeper into
space and talks of a future where we
might even live there we're going to
build a road to space and then amazing
things will happen to build towards that
future blue origin is constructing
bigger rockets that can carry larger
payloads into space and
he has plans to send reusable landers to
the moon it's time to go back to the
moon this time to stay if he gets up
there he may find he has some company
you see elon musk too has spoken of
ambitions to colonize other planets and
his company spacex has won a 2.9 billion
dollar contract to build moonlander for
nasa blue origin also tried to win part
of that work and is now suing nasa
saying that the agency's decision around
the lander was improper and while
spacex's website may be somewhat more
discreet about it than others the
company is still willing to take paying
customers into space if the price is
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's that you don't care about
colonizing the moon and you just want to
know what kind of experience your
millions will get you okay let's go
with virgin galactic you'll board a six
six-passenger spacecraft that's hanging
from a plane you'll be flown up to 45
000 feet which is around nine miles high
dropped and then rocketed up to an
altitude of around 50 miles up which is
one definition of where space begins
you'll experience around three minutes
of weightlessness before the pilots
glide you back down to earth it's this
last part that recently got virgin in
trouble with the faa after virgin said
their craft shifted out of its planned
trajectory during descent seats cost
upwards of 450 000
and the flight lasts around 90 minutes
in total
with blue origin you're strapped into an
automated capsule atop a rocket which
will fire you directly up into space the
entire ride is much quicker taking you
up there and back in around 12 minutes
but you'll still experience three
minutes of weightlessness
we don't know how much tickets will cost
yet but at an auction to be on the first
flight someone bid 28 million in the
front and he looks very excited about it
while the flight may be shorter blue
origin will take you higher than virgin
to the carmen line a more
internationally recognized edge of space
that sits at 62 miles up now where
virgin galactic and blue origin are
offering more of a packaged experience
spacex seems to be going for more of a
custom expedition approach
while there aren't any particular
details on the kinds of trips that they
offer they are still sending paying
customers into space
and i mean much further into space in
september they became the first to
launch a craft carrying four civilians
and no government astronauts into space
one of the astronauts paid an
undisclosed sum for himself and three
others to be there and they were
launched into an orbit higher than the
international space station for three
whole days using their automated craft
we're cruising right now at 580
kilometers above the earth going about
7.6 kilometers per second spacex has
also sold four commercial flights to the
international space station to a space
company called axiom who have sold
tickets for 55 million dollars now my
colleague micah maydenberg has actually
been following spacex closely and he
spoke to one of the people that were on
that september launch
i asked jared isaacman you know who who
purchased this trip you know from spacex
and i said jared you know how do you
think about this is this a tourism
flight and he he said no it's not you
know this is this is a mission it has a
bigger goal
it's about getting us deeper into into
space and sort of onto the moon and mars
and so forth they are going to be doing
research tasks on board they're going to
be doing projects related to their own
bodies but i think you know
other folks would sort of look at the
the simple nature of the transaction and
the trip itself and say
yes this this in in some sense is a
tourism flight i guess it's sort of like
this like tourism is a state of mind in
a way
now a spacex executive recently said
that the company has a backlog of
commercial astronaut missions
so whether spacex says it's a space
tourism company or not it will still be
a rival to virgin galactic and blue
origin's business plans after all one of
the things that's keeping those ticket
prices high is the exclusivity of the
trip so the more companies that begin
operating in that space the less value
those tickets have
hey mike has written some really great
pieces on the billionaires space race so
if you want to read more of his coverage
i've left the link below and whether
you're a millionaire or not don't forget
to subscribe see you soon
[Music]